this is a silicon chip it's the brain of
a smartphone it's about a centimeter
squared and has a small section in the
middle made up of 300 million
transistors with connections spreading
out like fingers to talk to the screen
the camera the battery or more but
imagine a chip with no transistors at
all instead there's a small chamber
that's controlling the processes and
energy levels inside of atoms this is
quantum computing the next frontier of
machines I think not in bytes but
powerful qubits but how powerful are
Cubist's well when five are strung
together through a process called
entanglement a chip can scan millions of
words in a book simultaneously rather
than line by line there are two main
approaches that scientists and
technology companies are exploring one
called superconducting involves making
artificial atoms and is being pursued by
Google and IBM the other one is called
cold atoms where you use real atoms and
trap and call them it's slow up but
potentially more efficient there are at
least 18 other large corporate groups in
the world that have invested in the
commercialization of quantum computing
there's obvious players like Google
Microsoft and IBM and less obvious ones
like Airbus and ababa and Lockheed
Martin qubit chips should eventually
find their way into phones and personal
devices but experts say that still
around 10 years out one of the first
applications will likely be cryptography
or to put it another way your passwords
which a quantum codebreaker machine
could easily crack no password is safe
[Music]